Moi si j'ai bien une qualité
C'est que je fais jamais de fautes d'orthographe
Faux !
Les gens qui écrivent bien, ceux qui ne font pas de fautes d'orthographe
Ils aiment bien te foutre la honte en lisant et en corrigeant ce que t'as écrit.
Légume, accent aigu les légumes.
Heu.. Soupe..
Tu as.. Mais t'as écrit soupe avec 5 p (Hein ?)
Heureusement qu'il existe les claviers d'ordinateurs.
Chaque fois que je fais une faute, j'sors la même excuse..
Non, j'pense que ça doit juste être une faute de frappe.
Chose que tu peux pas faire quand t'écris avec un stylo !
Ah non, j'pense que ça doit juste être une faute de stylo
Bon, on a l'droit de se moquer des gens qui font des fautes, c'est bon enfant.
SAUF ! Sauf dans un seul cas où c'est absolument interdit...
Ouh là, mais y'a que des fautes. Comment tu sais pas écrire mec !
Ouais, mais c'est parce que j'suis dyslexique...
Désolé, c'est pas ce que je voulais dire. J'ai un profond respect pour toi et ta famille.
J'suis dyslexique...
Franchement, je l'ai tellement entendu, que j'ai l'impression que tout le monde est dyslexique.
Faut arrêter avec la dyslexie.
J'ai l'impression que quand t'es dyslexique, tu peux le dire à toutes les sauces, ça passe !
Pfff, t'arrives même pas à soulever l'étagère !
Oh ça va, j'suis dyslexique, OK ?
Ce qui est chelou, c'est que le mot dyslexie, qui désigne une maladie liée à l'orthographe
est lui-même le plus dur du monde à orthographier.
Genre les mecs, ils ont jamais pu écrire leur maladie une fois bien. DYSSELÉQUECIE !
Alors que le SIDA par exemple, c'est plus facile, enfin c'est...
Bon moi je fais des fautes mais sur des mots un peu compliqué quand même.
Par contre j'aimerais vraiment faire un commentaire sur une faute qu'on voit tout le temps.
C'est  les mecs qui font cette faute là : sa va ?
Juste, les mecs, apprenez-le une fois. Ça va c'est ç cédille.
Voilà, c'est, pour toute la vie c'est bon. Après, après c'est fini, y'a plus besoin de l'apprendre.
C'est comme le language texto.
Y'a des mecs qui écrivent en language texto, euh, mais pas que dans les textos, partout dans la vie.
Attends, t'imagines si tout le monde faisait ça ? Dans quelques années, ce serait le bordel !
Le Président de la République,  François Hollande,
se serait assis ce matin dans son siège de Président et aurait affirmé, à toute la presse.
"Tou va BI1 !"
Euh, bon, alors, une phrase qui sera peut être un jour culte
Euh,  peut-être pas, ou peut être, moyennement culte.
Moi quand j'arrive enfin à retenir l'orthographe d'un mot
C'est pas parce que je l'ai appris dans un livre
C'est toujours par des moyens mnémotechniques, un peu nuls...
Euh, bienvenue ça prend un 'E' ?
Ouais !
Ah ! J'vois qu'Monsieur est un littéraire.
Ah non, pas du tout, non, c'est parce que chez moi j'ai un paillasson "Bienvenue"
D'accord.
Euh, juste comme ça
Est-ce que t'aurais chez toi par hasard  un paillasson avec écrit "En l'occurrence" ?
Non ? Ok.
Mais si je fais des fautes d'orthographe, alors que je suis pas dyslexique, j'suis quoi ?
Bah, ça veut juste dire que t'es con ?
Ah parfait.
Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux sur ma page Facebook 'Norman fait des vidéos'. Merci pour cela...